you've seen her skills in that awesome
animated short fight versus tracer and
now we're going to get into Widowmaker
here on GameSpot's overwatch hero guides
Chris Watters here with Danny O'Dwyer to
talk about the sniper extraordinaire I
absolutely love Widowmaker somebody he
loved snipers in any video game she is a
super powerful sniper in the white hand
and let's first talk about her gun I
guess yeah cuz it's got two modes it
does it's got a straight-up sniper mode
and then it has a sort of a
semi-automatic mode and semi-automatic
mode mostly used for if you were stuck
in close quarters battles also really
handy if you've managed to take a lot of
health off an enemy just kind of finish
them off but the thing about our sniper
rifle is that it sort of needs a little
bit of charge to get up to full damage
so what you want to do is lock on to
enemies at a distance try and keep them
in your sights when it hits 100 you'll
get used to the pace of us you can hear
it as an audio cute as a visual cue and
basically just ping them on 100 what you
should also know those you don't always
have to get 100 if they're on half
health and they're getting sort of
bombarded by a bunch of other people
maybe just get up to 50 blast it off
blasted off bust it off get a couple of
shots in there and as Widowmaker you are
often taking apart people who can't see
you so if you can just hit them hard
really quickly it benefits your entire
team absolutely and remember you know
just because going for the headshot is
obviously awesome but a body shot that
Widowmaker does a lot of damage and
you've got a lot of other people on your
team who are also doing damage ready to
pick up wounded characters there are
some that you want to really kill
outright illusio because he's always
healing the little bastard but yeah
sniping lanes and who are your priority
targets would you say so it's
interesting you say about the headshots
I mean if you see another Widowmaker
you're basically in a headshot fight to
take the other one out if there is
another Widowmaker that's your
responsibility if there's a Hanzo that's
your responsibility often as well if
there is a bastion or a turret as long
as the lane permits it and you can get
the shot away without making yourself
too much of a target that's kind of your
priority as well to sort of deke in and
out and get a couple of shots off at a
distant turret can really help edit your
team so that's kind of what you want to
be going for you also want to be taking
out I mean any it's the same as far
right anyone who's got a high damaged
projectile you kind of want to be
focusing it on the big
characters and try and take off many as
much health from those guys as possible
so if you do see a road hog and you know
he's definitely one you want to go for
you he lumbers around a lot
I mean Winston is big but he kind of
moves too fast for you to take off like
good shots so I guess just use best
practices try and get the big ones if
you can if you can't you're a 100
percent sniper shot can really damage
attacking foes quite badly like a Reaper
a headshot is basically gonna kill them
so yeah just focus you're tired the mone
main thing is keep firing keep firing
always be putting fire on the enemies
and yes support characters as well you
want to knock them out you want to force
them even if you get the body shot on
them and their health goes really low
you're forcing them back from the front
you're forcing them to take a more
defensive posture which gives your team
an edge so let's talk now about how you
get to all those good sniper spots
grappling hook super-powerful straight
at a quake baby yeah you want to use
this thing to basically get up in the
air as much as you can get onto rooftops
you also need use it to move around
often the thing about Widowmaker is if
you're in a position that you're doing
good work the other team is gonna know
where you are almost immediately and
changed your tactics so you want to move
around you want to move around before
they think you're gonna move around and
the grapple hook is a really good way of
doing you can move to a different
slapping spot take a couple more shots
even go back to your original sniping
spot and then sort of using that venom
mind to basically cover your the
backdoor entrance a lot of people use
that as an attacking
projectile it doesn't really do enough
damage its main uses to let you know
somebody's flanking you
so as Widowmaker you basically just want
to keep moving around using that
grappling hook I mean if you're really
good and these are like CRO Widowmaker
strats you can use our coupling hooks to
do to really get some crazy airtime if
you hit spacebar while you're going up
in the air on the grapple hook it will
detach and you can basically fly in the
air so if you do that you can use that
to get over certain walls you can also
do that to snipe from crazy high
positions you want to do some hot air
Snipes yeah I mean when you get hit by
Widowmaker does that you not even mad so
if you can practice even practice
against bots for that it's a pretty
crazy
yeah maybe don't bust that one out in
your first Widowmaker match because the
Widowmaker is a super important part of
the team it's one of those moments
you'll see when a team is unbalanced
it'll say no sniper and so Widowmaker is
a great one to have in your repertoire
as someone that you feel solid playing
as and her ultimate is also a great
asset to your whole team because it
reveals enemy positions for sure I mean
it's base
a wallhack you put the infrared on and
you can see where everyone is regardless
of how far they are there is a tendency
to use this selfish need to get into a
good sniper spot and then sort of ping
it but you're totally right if you even
are killed and you've got your old
oftentimes pinging that allows the rest
of your team to see where everyone is as
well and in certain flash points
especially if there's like an attack
going on our point that can be the
difference of your team pushing the team
back allowing you to get in a good
sniper position for the next wave that's
coming so honestly a lot of these alts
take power up pretty quickly that's one
for me that I almost trigger
automatically just a minute I get it go
right when it comes up for sure cuz
you're gonna get a bucket you're gonna
get it like multiple times in a map
you'll get it back real quick and think
of the satisfaction of you plant lining
up that headshot from someone walking
around the edge now think of the road
hog on your team that can you have
someone immediately when they come
around the edge of the bastion who can
be lying in wait to shred the person who
comes around the edge it's so valuable
for sure I mean it exposes turrets it
exposes enemy snipers it really helps
out the whole team so there you have it
putting down the nasty snipe action as
Widowmaker have fun out there folks
be safe be deadly and come on back to
game spot for more overwatch hero guides
you